let's get more now on how this
particular region is affected by seismic
events I'm joined by Stephen Hicks a
seismologist at University College
London uh Stephen
as we're talking to you we're just
seeing a lot of the rescue workers and
one of the shots that we have seeming to
leave the site uh they seem to be moving
away with some speed uh why that is we
don't know maybe there's a fear that
there could be further collapse that's
happening it is very unstable or
potentially further aftershocks
um
Stephen in terms of the aftershocks that
we've had there were a number straight
after the Quake could there be be after
shocks happening still
uh yeah so um straight after the
earthquake about 11 minutes after there
was a magnitude 6.7 Aftershock and
generally for most uh earthquakes on
average we expect the largest Aftershock
to be one unit of magnitude less than
the main shock so hopefully that largest
Aftershock 11 minutes after might be the
largest Aftershock
um it gets in the area but we really
can't completely rule that out but there
will be
um tens of thousands of aftershocks uh
still occurring in the coming weeks to
months but those will their number will
gradually decrease over time so that was
the the Aftershock that was about 6.6
which in itself is substantial but you
you're hopeful that that would be the
worst of this particular quake
yeah I mean when we look at past
earthquakes on average that would be the
case but we can't there's a small you
know uh percent chance that that could
be stronger aftershocks or even a really
small chance of that there's another
earthquake larger than the main shock we
can't completely walk that out
and this is on a fault line it is known
to be an area where there are
earthquakes but no warning of of a
Quaker of this nature there's no way to
predict that this could have happened no
sadly we can't um predict earthquakes
accurately
um in space and time
um you know we can't pinpoint exactly
where and when an earthquake will happen
um this region default was sort of
identified in in some scientific papers
that there's potential for a large
earthquake which we've seen today
um but again they can't predict exactly
when they are going to happen they just
knew the hazard was there
um but it's definitely when I when I was
woken up this morning by the alert that
this earthquake had happened it's just a
complete nightmare scenario as a
seismologist you know what earthquakes
are capable of over many you know
thousands of years but this is just yeah
the worst kind of uh earthquake shallow
uh it's a very shallow earthquake
beneath the highly populated area very
strong earthquake in a region which of
course we can see the buildings just
can't withstand this level of shaking
and in terms of those buildings A lot
has been spoken about the kind of
buildings that are are constructed in
order to try to withstand these Quakes
but can any building realistically
withstand an earthquake of this
magnitude
that shallow and depth very close to it
um if we look at places like Japan and
California I think the recent
earthquakes in Japan have shown that
um yes the buildings can they're sort of
um they're built to absorb the shaking
them which move with the shaking
um but again yeah it's hard to know in
this particular sense because of the
sort of the the the the the frequency of
the shaken how how quickly those sort of
up and down movements occur over time
can be very variable between earthquakes
and so it's really hard to understand
but traditionally these sort of Middle
Eastern style houses would not withstand
anywhere close to this level of shaking
and in terms of of the actual shaking
itself the the Quake It the first large
Quake how do we know how long that that
actually lasted for that the most
significant shaking
so the the when we talk about
earthquakes we often talk about an
epicenter of an earthquake when we talk
about earthquakes this large the
epicenter is not just a single point
um this earthquake's actually ruptured
along a fault for about 400 kilometers
so imagine tearing a piece of paper and
a tearing for 400 performances long and
that's that rupture has occurred about
over about 100 seconds
um now that's sort of the ground rupture
so that's sort of the tearing of the
crust but then the shaken as well the
seismic energy and that could last for
um hundreds more seconds maybe
particularly when you've got
um sort of aftershocks occurring
straight after the earthquake so that
tearing of the Earth's crust as you
vividly describe it well that the Quake
will sort of have moved along that line
will it or will the whole line have
fractured at once
um so it will start in one point and
then move towards sort of the the
generally in One Direction so in this
case the earthquake started
at the epicenter close to the Syrian
turkey border and then it's moved to the
Northeast we think
um so that has taught you know that that
rupture has occurred about over 100
seconds
um and traveling at about 400 kilometers
in that time
when we talk about other parts of the
world famous for earthquakes I'm
thinking now of California and places
like that there's this fear that the big
one is coming the big one is coming
um is that what has happened here in
Turkey is this the big one or or could
there you know could it potentially be a
lot worse than this in the future well
sort of in recent decades a lot of focus
on the the earthquake hazard in Turkey
is focused on the northern part of the
country so um there we've got a large
fault line called the northern Anatolian
fault and this is where there was a
large earthquake in 1999 that sadly
killed a lot of people and those
earthquakes have appeared to move west
towards Istanbul so they're sort of
seismic Hazard of the Istanbul region
was focused on I think people were less
um
um there was less uh knowledge and maybe
sort of um understanding of this
earthquake zone to the to the east
Southeast of turkey this is called the
Eastern Anatolian fault Zone
um purely because I think that there
just hasn't been the same rate of
earthquakes there you can still have
large earthquakes but they just don't
occur as regularly in time so the last
earthquake in that region was probably
you know pre-1900s before we started to
recording instruments um uh on on
seismographs so I think that's sort of
that experience can sort of
um that whether you've felt an
earthquake before in a region can then
help you to sort of prepare for the next
one but if you haven't felt a strong one
then that can sort of obviously affect
your preparation
and it could presumably also lead to
complacency because you might think well
hang on that's the earthquakes in turkey
that's something that happens up around
Istanbul it's not going to affect us so
much down here in the south
and sadly some of the some of this
complacency you see in in a lot of
countries it can feed into sort of
cutting Corners when it comes to
developing developing new buildings so I
don't know exactly what the rules are in
Turkey regarding Building Development
but you do see some sort of level of
um uh cutting borders and so buildings
aren't always
um built to the same minimum uh safety
level that they should be for certain
earthquakes of their size but whether
enough whether the building regulations
were sufficient to account for this sort
of rare you know poster magnitude data
Creek in the Southeastern part of turkey
I'm not sure
okay Stephen Hicks seismologist uh very
good to talk to you thank you for your
time